and I'm thrilled to be invited to give a
lecture here so today I'm gonna give a
talk on tea
Network the model compression and a
hardware accelerator engine to
accelerate the compressed and neural
network a brief introduction of myself
and my advisor so currently I'm a fourth
year PhD student at Stanford and my
research interest is in computer
architecture for deep learning to
improve the energy energy efficiency for
neural networks running on the mobile
and embedded systems so this recent work
on deep compression and energy
efficiency various engine has been
published in nips and covered by the
next platform and this is my advisor
bill so bill is the professor at
Stanford and former chairman of CAS
department and he leaves us our CVA
group and also the chief scientist of in
media and hosts numerous titles and Wars
so this talk I'm going to talk about two
things the first one is deep compression
so how to compress the large deep neural
network models to make it small to run
efficiently on the mobile system and the
second part is e ie accelerator so it is
efficient in Furious engine that runs on
the compressed neural network model so
let's get started with the introduction
of deep learning the next wave of AI so
on the left hand side is the human brain
and on the right hand side is the
artificial neural network so the
artificial neural network is inspired of
our human brain that the signal flows
from our eyes and goes all the way to
the back of our brain and after the
stages of processing it can recognize
from the picture to tell you that this
is a cat so for the artificial neural
network it has men has an input layer
and many hidden layers and finally an
output layer it tries to construct a
highly nonlinear function so that it can
be widely applied to applications
ranging from image recognition speech
recognition natural and natural language
processing with applications such as
speech recognition and you made
recognition machine translation
robotics surveillance self-driving and
assistant driving but with all these
interesting applications what is the
problem of really deploying such deep
neural networks onto the mobile platform
say if you want to have an app that runs
deep neural networks on your phone
current the app developers suffers from
the large model size for example the
current the previous Alex net which is
email in 2012 has a model size of around
two hundred forty megabytes and we digi
not have eg 16 Network has a model size
about over twelve hundred megabytes but
App Store have the restriction that an
atom if it's over a hundred mile bytes
that you cannot download until you
connect to the to the Wi-Fi so this is a
comment that talking about more the
importance of compression coming here
behind you in saying that at Baidu the
number one motivation of compressing the
networks is to bring down the size of
the binary file so as the mobile first
company some comments are mobile only
companies frequently updated various
apps we had different app stores so it's
very sensitive to the size of the binary
files so if a new feature increased the
size by a hundred megabytes I will
receive much more scrutiny than one that
increases it by only ten megabytes so
it's very crucial to reduce the size of
the neural network model to make
software engineers and app developers
happy to make it to put it small enough
to put it into the mobile phone and
secondly our hardware engineers suffers
from the large model science so
especially given the limited resource
constraint of the embedded system so
what does a large model size mean so a
large model size means we have to pay a
lot of memory bandwidth to run such
Network models but comparing the energy
consumption of different operations we
can see that the memory reference is two
or three more organic magnitude than
those are you up operations such as add
multiply and ice Ram cache access so a
dram memory access takes as monitors 640
Pico joules comparable that only five
Pico juice if we fetch a parameter from
SRAM mm cache so reducing the model size
is very crucial if we want to deploy it
on invalid system giving the limiting
our resource on the other hand what
about deploying the neural network on
the cloud so it suffers from these
problems so first we have a network
delay say we upload our image to the
cloud and then get the result back given
say 0.1 second delay if you have a
self-driving car application running on
your on your car 0.1 second if you're
driving at 70 miles per hour that is
already 10 feet away and also for power
budget so the power consumption is a
major part of the total cost of
ownership of a datacenter so the power
budget is a crucial factor as well and
finally the user privacy so companies
like snapchat they want to preserve the
users privacy and don't want users or
users don't want to upload their images
to the cloud and then get the results so
it is if you have a some app that say
scans your credit card and to know those
numbers you don't want your credit card
to be uploaded to the cloud and then get
back
so essentially you want everything to be
done locally on your phone so that
motivates has to have an engine that can
run your network and deep learning
applications in real time on your mobile
devices so given those constraints we
proposed
two solvers the first one is deep
compression that comprised deep neural
network model size done to a very small
size so that it will run efficiently on
mobile so it has three main features
first one is it has a smaller size it
can compress the app and the mobile app
size by 35 times 250 times and the
second one is accuracy
so although the neural network model is
compressed it does not suffer from a Mac
receipt job they still have the same
accuracy as the original network and
finally speed up so we hope to have the
new perience running faster and have
lower latency running the compressed
model so the second solver is efficient
in furious ending which is a ASIC
accelerator that accelerates and runs on
the compressed model so it also has
three features the first one is offline
so everything we can run locally on the
mobile so no dependency on the network
connection a second feature is real-time
there's no network delay and have a high
frame rate and finally low-power so that
we can have a higher energy efficiency
and have our battery runs longer so
let's look at the first the deep
compression so it's a high light it can
comprise Alex now about 35 times
bringing down the model size from 240
mile dies down to only around six point
six megabytes and four v 2g network it
comprised by 40 s 49 times compressed
from the original model size five over
500 megabytes down to only evil over
minor bytes
so both cases there is no egg accuracy
loss so now the weights can fit on the
chip SRAM which takes 120 times less
energy than if you have to go to the
DRAM memory
so how is the deep compression
implemented so it is a pipeline
consisting of first we prune the network
and then we enforce with sharing on the
network so pruning says we remove the
redundant synapses from the network so
this is the original network that is
densely connected and this is the prune
network that redundant weights are
removed so next I have talked about how
do we eliminate the redundant
connections and the next step is apply
with sharing say this weight and this
weight are pointing to the same memory
location so both during earrings and
doing training they are updated and used
at the same time with the same value and
the final step is Huffman coding it's
not on this picture but I will talk
about it later so let's go through the
first one which is pruning pruning is
implemented by we tree in the network
like before and then we prune the
connections by finding the absolute
value of the weights if they are smart
and we remove them away and finally with
between the weights and we do it
iteratively to recover the accuracy so
after this pipeline the network can be
reduced by 10 times without losing
accuracy so this is a little bit of
motivation it's actually motivated by
our human brain so when we are born
trillions of snap-snap TSA's are
generated during the first a few month
of birth and then at 1 year old it
peaked at a thousand treaty and a 10
year old a child has only around 500
trillion connections so this result has
been published by Nature
saying that this pruning mechanism
removes the redundant connections in the
brain so we first develop a lot of
connections and then during which as we
grew up as we learn new stuff a lot of
redundant connections are removed so
only those useful connections
apses are preserved so does this
mechanism also work artificial neural
network so the answer is yes if you see
the results across four different neural
artificial neural networks across two
different benchmark prostitue different
data sets
this is unleased data set classifying
zero to nine of digits and this is
imagenet that has a thousand classes the
largest data set of image recognition so
the network can be comprised ranging
from Nyack's to 13x without losing the
accuracy some of them even have our last
error rate and this is a detailed result
on alex net through pruning this
horizontal is telling us how many
parameters are we removing away
so at this point we are removing 90% of
the parameters in the original network
and the y-axis is the accuracy loss it's
telling us how many accuracy do we lose
by pruning the network so of course the
more to the right left right upside the
better the result so this is the best
result telling us that removing 90% of
the parameters resulted in no accuracy
loss so these four lines are designed
space exploration of different pruning
methods including using our
regularization versus our tool
regularization and the dashed line our
pruning the network without retraining
the network so we can see that even
without retraining the network say if
you don't have the data set to retrain
you can still get around fifty percent
free lunch or pruning the network and
then an interesting point lies in this
line this green line on the top we can
see that sometimes they are
even got improved by finding the right
number of model capacity of the pruna
network but if we to prune too much the
accuracy will begin to drop so this
technique has recently been used by Hong
Kong University they are ellipse they
used pruning deliberately to increase
the accuracy of classifying detecting
faces and classifying faces so this
figure shows how many printers in each
layer of Alex that and we do Jeannette
are redundant and can be safely prune
away the green part is like the water in
that you can safely remove in a sponge
we can see that this is the total
parameters and all of these green parts
can be safely removed and so it is for
the vdg net around 93% of the
connections can be safely removed
without impacting the accuracy and if
you see the breakdown of the called
ocean layer versus the fully connector
layer so both come later and fully
connect a layer can be pruned but column
layer can be pruned less around three
times and I've see layers can be pruned
more about ten times and neroli the
first layer that directly interacts with
the input image have less redundancy
generally for both networks so let's see
what exactly does pruning do and what is
the pattern of the pruning Network so
this is a very basic illustration of on
the Abney's the data set that has digits
0 1 2 or 3 out of 8 or 9 so this is the
Linette 300 100 so the first and this is
the sparsity pattern of the first fully
connection layer of blood not 301 and
100 which is a fully connection
neural network classifying the digits so
the input is as image has 28 by 28
pixels so altogether six seven hundred
and sixty-four pixels that's the input
and the hidden layer first the hidden
layer have three hundred elements so the
first matrix of the network is basically
a 764 by 300 matrix so this is the
sparsity pattern of the matrix after
pruning we can see that it clearly has a
banded structure so if we can't there
are exactly 28 bands and each band have
exactly 28 pixels so why is it like that
and also the it is white here and also
white here so why is there like that
because if we see the data that all the
digits are mostly written in the centre
of the image so on the peripheral say
here and here here and here there's
nothing in the image so the connections
it's a pruning automatically fine finds
that those connections that connect with
these empty parts are useless
so that it can be safely pruned so these
part correspond to the first three
horizontal pixels first line second line
third line they are mostly white and
then these empty entries corresponds to
outer after at the beginning and the end
of when we scan the image these part are
empty and finally these empty parts
corresponds to the bottom of the image
that are mostly empty so that this
figure now this visualization can show
that the pruning mechanism automatically
finds the important connections that we
need to preserve in the image so it not
only learns not only learn is the weight
but also learns the connections not only
learn is the weight of the connections
but also learns which connections are
right to preserve in the neural network
so above we talked about the
applications for image recognition so
how about those are convolutional neural
networks
how about recurrent and recursive neural
networks and are STM's use the natural
language processing so this experiment
works on the neuro talk which is done by
Audrey her party upstairs and then it's
a application of the application is
doing the image captioning so I give you
an image and like the newer Network
generate the caption of the image so we
can see that with with no retraining the
Palouse core begins the job and with
proper retraining the Palouse core can
be preserved until we remove 90% of the
connections so it's really interesting
to see that about 90% of the connections
in your talk are redundant and can be
safely removed and also preserve a very
good performance so let's see these
examples so for the first picture the
original Network predicts say predicts
the caption to be a basketball player in
the white uniform is playing with the
ball and if we turn away 90% of the
connections the network produces the
results saying that a basketball player
you know what uniform is playing with a
basketball so it's even more accurate
than pong and how about the second was
the original network says a brown dog is
running through a grassy field and they
said the protein networks say that a
brown dog is running through a grassy
area they're almost the same and for
this one the origin network says the man
is riding a surfboard on the wave and if
you prune away 90% of the parameters it
says a man in the wetsuit is reading a
wave on the beach so this seems like
something like a pitch although not a
I think something yellow
but if we are too greedy and prune away
too much parameters the network becomes
drunk totally drunk we are totally drunk
apart a little bit the original artwork
says a soccer player in red is running
the field and the perimeter says a man
in a red shirt and black and white black
shirt is running through a field it's
not logically correct but we can see
there is still white black and red
shirts so this shows that the pruning
also applies to not only see him smile
ireland's and our CMS so just now we see
the function and performance what about
the speed-up
so I experimented with the FC layers of
Alex that we did in that and neuro Talk
and on three different platforms the
intel i7 cpu the immediate gtx attacks
GPU and also the immediate tk1 mobile
GPU so i used i experimented with both
the dense network and the probe network
and compare compare there's bees on one
two three four five ones online
benchmarks and this is that you mean so
if we if you see the average so the
Principia the pruna network is roughly
three acts faster than the i'm for
network and on the GPU it's also roughly
three acts faster than done from the
network i know more about GPU it's
roughly five times 3 divided by 0.6
faster than running on the unpruned
network so there are some cases where
there's no speed up for example this one
cpu 3 DG 8 so this layer is already
small enough that even though it has a
size of 4 K by 4 K so it's already folk
a buyer thousandth or a 4k by a thousand
so the unfurl network is already small
enough to fit in cache so the pro
network also even got prune its doofus
in the last level cache so the speed-up
is not
very significant but if you see those
large layers say vgg six it has as much
as nine times speed up on the CPU
because the pro network and forty feet
on the l3 cache but the Emperor network
cannot some details the unproven etwork
is implants Imperial symbol with I'm KRC
velocity Emily and the prominent work is
implemented CSR Emily and similarly on
GPO the pro network is implemented cr0
sparse library coos bars and I'm for
networks implement this is cool blast so
what about the energy efficiency running
those layers so on average does if you
see here on the CPU is roughly takes six
times last energy and on GPU takes three
times at last and I'm about to here
takes roughly four times less than the
unpruned network ok so having talking
about pruning we switch gear to
quantization and with sharing so
conversation and with sharing are
implemented in with this method
so we first clutter the weights by sake
in classroom and then we generate the
code book and then we quantize the
weights according to the code book
and finally we retrain the code book and
easily do this process and by reducing
the network by another Tony Sanneh acts
2:31 acts we can get preserve the same
accuracy by proper retraining so what is
the retraining like if you see this
picture it is a four by four matrix and
the weights with the same color are
quantized with the same value say if
this weight is 2.09 and data beta is 1.9
- then they are both quantized to two
and then having an index of three
pointing to this location so when doing
updates these are the gradient generated
by say cafe
and then this gradient is grouped by the
index there are the weights where the
same color are grouped with the same
same row here and then they are reduced
by summing these greens together and
then finally these reduce the weights
are multiplied with a learning rate and
a miners to buy the original essentially
weights and this concludes one iteration
of the updates so what is the benefit of
this so let's see what is attitude we
need to store previously and now
previously we need to store all these 16
weights each weight if it's a
floating-point number that's 32 bits or
1/2 bit or 16 bit now we only need to
store the four four numbers the centroid
plus the index so in this case the index
can be represented with the only two
bits instead of previously 32-bit and a
codebook is only four has only four
entries but this is still using a 32-bit
fault so if you see a real distribution
of the weights
Alex Matt so these are the weights after
pruning and Retraining we can see that
everything that's close to zero has been
eliminated after retraining so it's
roughly forms and bimodal distribution
so the green dots here Green Cross is
here are the initialization of these
centroids
but after clustering and fine-tuning the
weights the codebook are those red dots
so those meanings of connections here
can be represented in only these 16 dots
only these 16 red dots to represent the
origin network so for example the FC 7
layer of Alex 9 has 60 million
parameters but now you have only you
have to only store 16 parameters and
their indexes so that's a huge saving so
in this year snips there is a another
work doing even
more aggressive colonization by making a
they were only one bit so plus 1 and the
minus one they showed their result on
I'm nice to decide and cipher base I
said but I'm really looking forward to
their result on the image net they said
as well but this figure roughly shows
the shape of say this is plus 1 and this
is minus left the shape is very similar
so the result so 60 million parameters
now you can have only 16 parameters so
if we have a 12 bit condition means calm
layers represent the 8 bits I've see
layers represented by 5 bits
there's no accuracy lost image net data
set an 8 4 bit quantization which is a
little bit more hot were friendly to 4
bits or 8 bit which is a bite
there is only 0.1 top one
I'll Chris a large plus which is kind of
negligible and then if you want to be
more aggressive so if you are really
limited by a hardware resource and you
don't care a little bit of a crystal
I'll say 2 percent or 2.6 percent you
can more aggressively comprise it to
only 4 bit or 2 bit for the network so
those results are astonishing so let's
see the detailed breakdown of each layer
of the Alex net so the x-axis is the
number of bits we preserve say this is 8
bit 7 6 5 4 3 2 all with the 2 bits and
the y-axis is the address the insurance
accuracy so if you see the common errors
not until the three bits three bits or
four bits does the accuracy begin to
drop and for the absolute layers not
until two bits does the accuracy begin
to top so this shows that there's a lot
of redundancy in the network and just
now we have seen both pronia and
quantization so these two methods both
reduce the model capacity and the size
of the neural network so one law
my mum question that we may have is can
they work together to further bring down
the size of the neural network the
answer is yes so this is let's see these
three figures are I've seen layers and
calm layers and all the layers and these
this is the top five accuracy and this
is the top one accuracy so there is a
dash line and a solid line meaning both
prune and quantize network and the quant
has the only network showing in I see
this one showing in - we can see that
this solid line works even better than
this dashed line meaning that the
quantized and the pro network works even
better than if you quantize the network
only so why is it like that if we see
the distribution here pruning which is
make the distribution in blue like this
alright of roughly quantize the network
into binarize the network say this is
one group this is no power this is one
group this is another group so it
already helped the quantization a little
bit and furthermore pruning reduced the
number of connections that you have to
quantize say previously you have a
10-minute out or you have 16 million
parameters to prune - to quantize now
you only have one one meeting parameters
to quantize that makes the quantize even
easier so that's why pruning and
quantization can work very well together
so lastly so the final step of the
compression pipeline is Huffman coding
so this is a lossless compression
technique working on both the weight
weight and the index and the motivation
is that both the weight and the index
are piously it is tributed so if we can
represent the weight that occurs more
frequently say this one and use the last
use more number of bits
to represent the weight that doesn't
occur very frequently use very little
bits here and use a variety of bits of
representation it can further bring down
the model size although this method in
these Huffman encoding and decoding in
the inference stage so I didn't did not
implement this line in hardware but
implementing the compression software so
if we apply the whole compression
pipeline the pruning quantization and
Huffman coding we can comprise the
network these four networks ranging from
35 times to 49 times without increasing
the test error for all these cases so
here is a comparison of different
methods so the x-axis is the compression
rate say here we compress the network by
five percent of its original size and
this one shows the accuracy loss so if
we apply both pruning and quantization
the network can be comprised all the way
down to around say three percent of the
original size without losing accuracy
but if we apply pruning only it begins
to an also quantization only the
accuracy begins the job when is
comprised about ten percent of its
original sites furthermore if we apply
the relatively cheap SVD the singular
value decomposition technique to
approximate the matrix we can compress
the network by only around 20 percent
then the accuracy begins begins to drop
here so the the thing that worked best
is the pruning plus quantization the red
line here
so here's a detailed breakdown of
different layers on the left-hand side
of the Alex net so with the whole
pipeline is comprised two to 0.88 of his
original size but without Hoffman coding
is still compressed to about 3.7 percent
of his original size and the layers are
presented with eight bits or comp later
and five bits for DFC layers so here's a
comparison with other published
compression methods so the pruning plus
colonization process half monk odeon
worked best compared with other
compression methods find on the
literature so here's a conclusion of
network deep compression so we have
presented method to compress deep neural
networks without losing mirror accuracy
by first pruning the way those and
important connections and then quantize
the network and enforce with Sharri and
finally apply Huffman coding the network
can be comprised by 30 time acts ranging
from 3 to 5 X - 14 X without losing the
accuracy so now all the weights can fit
in cache and can motivate us to build a
specialized hardware accelerator that
works on this compressed model if we
think of the compressed model it is a
sparse model it has indirect lookups
which is now that Hardware friendly on
those customize hardware that's why
later I build a hardware accelerator
that works song the commands d'amato and
by the way as a product we are going to
get a model compression tool for
developers who very interested so we're
going to produce two versions an easy
version so no retraining is these needed
it's very fast can have around five
times the 10x compression rate and
giving given about 1% accuracy loss and
we're gonna produce the advanced version
which have 35 times 250 times
compression rate with no loss of
accuracy but training is needed it
requires some training time
and this is a demo of Alex net pocket
Alex net that's very small that you can
put in pocket that's why I call it
partly I accept roughly only eight
megabytes so on the with the compressed
model the next step of my work is to
build a be very efficient inferiors
engine that works on the compress the
model to give even larger speed-up and
even more make it even more
energy-efficient by building a
specialized the hardware accelerator so
this is the hot work salary so we are
going to build so it has three features
first of us writing offline you don't
have to upload your feed image the cloud
and then it's real time no network delay
and high frame frame rate I found in low
power as high energy efficiency that
preserves your battery so how do we up
achieve those three goals so the main
motivation and the main solution is put
everything on chip so previously we have
seen that picture that memory reference
is really expensive compared with other
operations like area operations and
cache axes and everything else it's two
or three organs more order of magnitude
than those are pressures so after
compression everything can completely
fit on tip so that you don't have to go
to off chip to fetch those parameters
from DRAM so that gives you both speed
up and energy efficiency
so we present a sparse indirectly index
which shared matrix vector accelerator
that accelerates the compressed model
the absolute leaders of the compress the
model now the large gene models can fit
on chip on Tobias Ram with which is 120
X energy saving band go into D ramp and
then the e ie
efficient if you're sending a plot
exploit the sparsity of the activation
as well since after rattle operation the
activation also becomes sparse most of
them are zero so if we don't do
commutation on those 0 accusations we
can save
another three times commutation time and
also EIU works on the compressed model
which with a half encoding is 30 times
model reduction compared with the
original model so you you do less work
so you do 30 times last vegetable 30
times less parameters and for each
parameter you save 120 X energy so for
the accelerator I distributed both the
storage and communication across
multiple peas so that you can scale your
system with your application if your
application needs a large network then I
have a lot of such piece but if you have
a small scene from this picture if you
have a large network can have more peas
here but do you have a small application
with a small model I can only say I have
say four peas so that you can scale your
problem scale your system with a problem
and fun way we evaluated a ie on a wide
range of deep learning models ranging
from 64 operated - RS TM for natural
language processing and image captioning
and also compared with GPU CPU GPUs and
other ASIC accelerators so this figure
shows how how do we distribute the
storage and processing across different
peas so showing you this figure this is
the matrix in a certain hidden layer of
a deep neural network and the weights
you can see there are a lot of zeros
corresponding to we have Pro network so
that are a lot of zeros and a lot of
them so the weights with the same color
are stored in the same PE so that it's
distributed i'm partitioned in the rope
in the gold miner
so this HP you can process its own part
it does a local reduction without too
much communication with other piece
while you process a single element and
then inside each PE
it goes through these three steps so
first of all the input of the engine is
comprise the deep neural network model
and the input image and so that we store
the encoded weight
yes ram relative index yes Ram with a
sparse format and and then we fetch the
4-bit were too late and the 4-bit
relative index remember this is only for
bit compared with the original 32-bit
floating-point or 16-bit half fluting
half precision floating point and then
for the weight we do a week lookup and
for the index with the index
accumulation since it's a relative
indexed and then we get a real weight
and there under absolute index so that
we can using you use the real way to do
AR you are produced and they use the
absolute index to fetch the code for
fetch the printer from the code book
finally we do the prediction and get the
result so this hot work Sal Reiter is
evaluated with the standard Isaak design
floss so first of all we build a secure
accurate it's impossible simulator that
has two abstract methods propagate and
update so this simulator is used for
design space exploration later served as
a coda model for the verification of the
era log and the next step with the with
the with the simulator we have the RTL
written in very log that we have
verified this output with the golden
model in them in models in a next step
we synthesize the key I use in the
synopsis design compiler under the TSM
c-45 TP library which we used standard
VT library with worst case PBT corner to
make sure everything works correctly and
finally we placed in rotted the PPE
using the synopsis IC compiler the icc
and we use the cacti to get the FM area
and energy numbers and in order to get
the power consumption order the
compulsion sumption we have annotated
total rate from the ITR illumination to
the
at least remember the power consumption
is the equation is CV square and times
frequency so we need we can get see the
capacitance from the post post layout
libraries and library libraries from the
post layout circuit and via we can get
it from the library as well and F the
frequency we have to get it from the
simulation result which is annotated
with dumped into a switch activity
interchange format the same format and
estimate the power using the primetime
TPX tool and then we baselined the
hardware diffusion diffusion in here is
ng these benchmarks which is alex engine
from alex not VD t net and neuro talk
and run it on compared with GP cpu GPU
and mobile GPUs and this is the layout
of a row tip so this is this is the ice
ramp that stores the sparse matrix
sparse matrix and this is the ice ramp
that stores the pointers and in insight
here is the is the meat which is
arithmetic unit so as we can see still
most of the chip area is consumed by the
eyes ramps so the under TSMC 45
nanometer it consumes nine milli watts
for each PE and taking an area of 0.6
millimeter square and the critical path
of the engine is 1.15 nanometers so 64
so 48 such PE is large enough to hold
alex net so you can scale the number of
peas with your problems s so without
model compression we can outfit all the
printers on those ass ramps but we only
with model compression can we fit
everything on chip that's the merit
merit of yeah
so let's see the speed-up of and the
energy efficiency of a ie so this is the
speed-up and this is the energy
efficiency so across different
benchmarks the right hand side is the
ABS is the average value so previously
we have seen these bars now we have a
new bar here so we can see that the e I
Eng which is in red is a hundred and
thirty nine times faster than CPU
running the uncompressed model and it's
roughly eighteen times faster compared
with the GPU with running the
uncompressed model and with respect to
the energy efficiency the red bar which
is e IE is 24,000 times compared with
the CPU running on the uncompressed
model and is roughly 3,000 times more
energy efficient than the GPU is running
the uncompressed the model so where are
these numbers cut where does this number
come from the 3,000 times more energy
efficient than CPU or than the GPU so if
we do a hand calculation so by
compressing the network we can save
around 30 times of we have 330 times
last model size and last parameters to
fetch from from either I or MOT RAM and
then since we compress the model and
everything fits in is RAM the SRAM is
another 120 times more energy efficient
than fat in fetching from DRAM I
remember we can utilize the sparsity of
the activation which is roughly three
times sparse possible sparsity so all
the way there is roughly if you do the
calculations roughly 10,000 times more
energy more energy efficient but this is
using 45 nanometer technology and the
GPUs are done GTX Titan so divided this
number by 2 we can roughly
five thousand times I should
theoretically five thousand times more
energy fusion
so probably we didn't do it good enough
we're gonna get three thousand times so
let's see the speed-up by benchmarking
with CPU GPU and mobile GPU so these are
the those are really small numbers but
different benchmarks with different
batch size so this this mg is targeting
real-time process in which the number is
of the previous figure our generator
using batch size of one
so during say self-driving car you don't
have the time to batch 64 images and
wait and he or 64 images to come and
process them together that's why we use
batch size of one to do the benchmark so
this figure shows the scalability of a
ie
ranging from one PE all the way to 256
PE s so the scalability longest ago is
roughly linear speed-up except for this
one so the neuro Talk w e this matrix is
really small so in with 256 P's
considering the sparsity HP has around
just one atom into process so that when
there are a lot of piece it does not
grow that much for this ventrac but for
the rest the scalability is really good
and this figure shows the number of
useful computation on the top across
different piece and also the load
balance for with the different number of
peas the useful computation some of them
is not 100% because with the relative
index we have to pad zeros if we cannot
use 4 bits to represent the jump we have
to pad a dummy 0 over there so that the
usable computation is less than 100% but
with more piece the more PE we have the
last padding:0 we need so that the news
for the televisions computations becomes
more and this is analysis of the low
the balance with more peace so the more
peace we have HP you will have less
number of parameters to process thus
it's highly possible that some peas have
three parameters some of them have eight
parameters process leading to temporary
load imbalance so how do we deal with
this so we introduce the 505 volke you
that decompose the computation between
different teas so we have a couple of
different sizes 1 2 4 8 16 we
experimented with different file size to
see the load balance feature of the EIA
engine we can see that the load balance
becomes pretty well when the file size
is roughly of size 1 2 3 1 2 4 8 here
another motor size of 8 the Akane became
the benefit becomes marginal so we
choose in the design we choose the file
size to be 16 here and here's more
design space exploration of the ie Angie
so on the top this is the design space
exploration of the answer and width so
the whiner dies Ram the last number of
red showing shown in we need but the
more energy it takes
reading reading each parameter but if we
multiply them together we will see the
total energy we can see a 64 bit the
width of the SRAM gives the most
efficient usage so we choose the design
of the SRAM width to be 64 bit and also
we have unanalyzed arithmetic precision
after the quantized weights so we so in
the codebook in previously remember we
quantize all the weights with codebook
so that 16 million parameters became
only 16 parameters and those 16
parameters how many bits do we use to
represent the weight play a larger role
in the energy efficiency so we can see
that the 30 32 bit floating point
multiplier takes roughly 4 Pico joules
but a 16 bit in
operation takes roughly only half a
pickled war which it's a lot more
efficient and then we experimented with
the accuracy from the little bit float
to a 32 bit int to 16 bit int we can see
not until using 32 16 bit integer does
the accuracy begins to drop with the
8-bit integer the accuracy becomes
undone usable so that we choose the
arithmetic precision of the code book to
be 16-bit integer operation so the AI
engine has recently been covered by the
next platform
title of the merging chip accelerates
deep neural networks and we see if we
see the big picture if we say that Intel
defined the chips that does computation
in the PC era and then Qualcomm and
Samsung and far away and those companies
defined the mobile competition in the
mobile era then what is the next
generation of chips that defines the era
of the intelligent mobile computation
and I hope that deep learning Hardware
of for deep learning such as AI e can
shed some lights and give some
interesting motivation and and and pave
the way for future chips that targets
intelligent mobile computation so here
is a conclusion of my talk we presented
a ie an efficient energy efficient
engine optimized to operate on the
compressed deep neural network which is
done by pruning weight sharing and
Huffman coding by elaborating the
sparsity in both the activations things
we have read will attribution function
and the weights yeah he reduced energy
consumption of typical oscillator by
3,000 times
and this is the breakdown of how does
where does these three thousand times
come from
so first compression and then dear I'm
Timaeus Ram and finally sparse
activation that's my talk the questions
generalizing your matrix vector
representation into a sensor into the
tensor so complicated deals with single
matrix vector multiplication with batch
size of one currently does not support
tensor operation right this moment so
once you've done the pruning of course
you can't train on a different training
center because it might have hot wires
that really put substantive weights on
the links that you remove right so if I
retrain if I wanted to train on a
different training set different trees
and it had it would have not made zero
waves on some of the links but once you
prune them it's all it's all done you
can never put a weight there because
there's no link right right say as we
see from the digits listen data set the
digits are written on let's say a lots
of times said exactly because I have to
wait prove that that's working have a
different path but for but for example
in speech recognition
they're always improving because they're
continually retraining based on
continual input might that not lead to
positive weights where you from the link
link with the new that oh it should be a
new problem with the say online learning
when you constantly have different data
sets
yeah then you cannot fix the
anyway yeah so this is what I still need
to do compression or not so here there
are three terms if you're tier I means
as farm is large enough that can hold a
lot of friends you can lose one of the
terms here but you still have the rest
of the terms I think and then generally
if you have an app if you build it up
writer and you want to have a lab on our
APIs or you want to use a condom don't
have very fast things you need to have a
relatively small app just depends on the
game if the hard work continues to say
in one day you can have a really really
large the DRAM SRAM them probably will
talk as it needs those really aggressive
compression but compression can still
gain you some something maybe not that
much 3,000 times but maybe say three
hundred times
so you saw the compression to comparison
with SVD approximation to the wave
matrix right you can you know to
compress and what you did SVD
you retrain for that you can you can
retrain vectors to move them around
I sympathize with the opinion between
the singular vectors given the it's not
you I also tested with not between the
proto model and not between the
quantized model and seems like even with
our retraining it's less optimistic if
you just do the eyes videos already
begin to fall pretty sharply when you
decrease the model science and there's a
detailed paper about is really published
in I believe in nips last year by
Facebook and so the most version of
wandering so like when you're pruning
you typically the biggest savings comes
from you know a lot of these commnets
don't actually use only gonna get
waivers now it's a competition layers
all the way through so it's almost like
they proved out there are some
structures in with and then they trained
and already the networks 30 times
smaller every still get very good result
so do you think it's I think the
structure compression is a really good
thing for example the Google and Mac
which is really really small and then I
exactly have the same thinking when I
visited by two so they have a face
recognition network that almost all the
layers are
cultivators and only have one Fc layer
and they still using my technique to
compress their model by ten times to
make it even smaller to put in by those
face recognition app
so I think the final solution I
appreciate most is applying both methods
so first in structure structural
compression and then those deep
compression techniques I described to
make it smaller to have to the limit any
more questions
you